federal government has a new message for
Airlines weighs passengers time and you
may have to pay new regulations would
require carriers to compensate flyers
for long delays or cancellations if it's
a situation that was under the airline's
control Chris Van Cleef has more
to the 76 percent of Travelers worried
their next flight will be delayed or
canceled the Biden Administration is
saying we hear you our top priority has
been to get American Air Travelers a
better deal the Department of
Transportation will now start drafting
new regulations aimed at requiring
Airlines to essentially pay Flyers if
their lengthy delay or cancellation is
the airline's fault the new regulations
will also likely set requirements for
when Airlines must pay for a meal Hotel
Transportation as well as rebooking
Flyers when their trips are disrupted
and providing timely customer service
rules similar to those in Europe ticket
prices will go up plain and simple
that's what happened in Europe that's
what will happen here this is a shot
across the airline industry's bow
Airline analyst Henry hartevelt does
this make flying better for passengers
do you think it certainly gives
Travelers more of a leg up than they
have now because it will codify what
they they should expect from their
Airlines I'm worried about the
unintended consequences of this though
could this raise airfares if the costs
are deemed too great what won't be
covered delays and cancellations due to
weather traditionally the biggest cause
of flight disruptions
the new rules could take off by the end
of the year for CBS mornings I'm Chris
Van Cleave in Phoenix